welcome to this 15-minute game playing
against Graham from the UK let's see
what opening do we get I haven't played
it before right no t4c for the green
felt on the Kings Indian okay the Kings
Indian good Father's getting really
popular these days yeah it seems to be
very young yeah what is hard to say when
on top level they probably would call it
even reliable but for a normal players
yeah I don't know it seems to be in a
very healthy theoretical state that
green front nowadays the Kings Indian is
some not regarded so so highly at the
moment okay all we have transposed from
the classical line in the Kings Indian
with the c-54 f transpose now to the
barrack see bind normally originating
normally coming from the Sicilian
actually or from a symmetrical English
both them are very valuable move orders
okay played a 6 mm
yeah father the usual musiah Bishop d7
takes on d4 well a six of course has
been played as well even rookie aid has
been played by then blossom why I'm
thinking a bit as I normally like to
play those positions with night back to
see two yeah retreating this in order to
keep more pieces on the board and I'm
wondering if I should do that now
because after Bishop d7 I would have
retreated also and that later but should
be six is quite often a useful move also
a six is useful to wonder if I may be
just like a moves down if i do that if i
should play some other moves that could
be helpful in any case so i go for that
let's see what he's doing don't think
that this temper one is so so crucial if
it is a tempo at all but so it's not
clear that he will play know that it
will play but should be six them in the
first place okay well the normal the way
I'd like to set up here is Queen to d2
f3 making sure that the center is
well-protected f3 rook FC one rook a b1
and possibly even before nine to d5 this
kind of moves of course it's all a
question what like it's doing so I'm not
doing all those moves automatically I
must check what he's doing for instance
after 95 here which is mostly played
here I have after this position I
probably had on the board for like
dozens of times Knight a5 there is night
to a3 covering see form it does not look
so great but it's for fulfilling a very
useful role in covering the pawn and b3
has one very this one big disadvantage
as it loosens
the C 3 square so there are tactics like
with b5 Queen c7 coming so I want to
avoid that a night on a 3 has another
additional virtue it controls the b5
square so that b5 by black is much more
difficult to play then with the pole and
b3 another important idea is that if you
go screen a5 now which is very often
played then i have the interesting
response rook a2 b1 the idea being to
play b4 b4 night Queen takes a three
rugby three at the Queen strapped yeah
well I'm telling you all this because I
had it on the board like dozens of times
and in blitz and all kinds of time
controls and this is why I know this
stuff so well the maroc CM you get so
often if you play night air 3c four
openings okay here I go 95 this is also
why f3 is a move that white should play
early in covering e four so that you can
always put it on d5
yeah here um yeah black normally or else
brought to say takes with some peace
it's not so clear with them what what's
the better peace I normally hear capture
with the sea porn very often in the
maracas see you want to take with the
pawn and then pressure put pressure on
the e7 pond with the opening fathered
here the whole piece configuration is
just not set up for this type of plane
so here I'm going for a queen side
focused play okay um yeah probably just
Roxy one need to put it there anyway an
important feature of this position is
the e5 Knight if you look closely you
see that the e5 Knight has nowhere to go
it's only five but it has absolutely no
peace vodka nope no place where they
could go to and for instance if I had
played age three or if I play a tree in
the near future f4 would threaten to
actually trap the night in the middle of
the board this is something that black
must be aware yeah it's not so easy for
black e'er to do anything active very
often black players tried to play be
five in this position trying to I am not
quite sure what to display some activity
maybe but it's one of those cases where
you weaken yourself on the side where
you are where you are worse okay he's
played f5 this is an entirely different
way to play it's an interesting trying
because it takes my Center and it
probably threatens in a way to take on
e4 takes on e for every form and I he
has got a very strong right then
my response is pretty much forced any
two loops I need to take on f5 yeah
simply because he's ready to her to take
on e four so I'm here it's interesting
how should I proceed here something some
need to be noted I can also easily play
Bishop h6 trying to exchange this
because of Queen B 6 check this is some
quite quite annoying I could think about
Bishop g4 though thats that is a is a
plan actually trying to play Bishop d 4
+ f4 exchanging this special on g7
another good idea could be to put the
night see to deform to try to go to e6
but this no it's not not really working
so well at the moment I'd like to do
that this is actually I think I move
that I like with maybe a for exchanging
that putting the queen or deform would
be quite nice term you know and I also
like to get my night back into the play
and this would be possible actually
after move like f4 f4 night moves to
don't know f7 maybe and then I can also
go Knight to c4 getting it into play on
an active square not putting it on c2
maybe f 49 move taking on g7 then
checking on d4 and then night c4s maybe
the most precise way to play maybe it
depends a bit on what he's doing here to
be honest I have a creative suggestion
for black maybe it's just [ __ ] sorry
for the right sorry and let's say beef
g5g five ok this is really nonsense I
can just take it yeah ok I had an idea
which is completely completely Broncos
g5 community hd5 night f3 check Bishop
f3 Bishop takes d4 check getting the
good dark squared bishop but this is
entirely against the rules of chess so
g5 is really sounds like an idea after a
couple of glasses of wine yeah let's see
what is he doing now
hmm not quite sure what you want to
recommend you for black there are some
some issues I mean it's not so easy to
find a good move some some moves
normal-looking moves I have very severe
problems like windy Sanders those g4
okay so i can play a foreign area should
i do that yeah i guess what else could
you do besides night wait okay I'll do
that this was the plan anyway I was just
thinking maybe you can go now Bishop to
h6 button okay if I take on g7 now and
then not sure then the Queen and then
night see for one night c 4 immediately
is this any better not sure not sure
taking on g4s probably not leading to
anything right no probably not does it
make any sense to take on c8 actually
not clear I'm taking it them I can do
first don't see a drawback really and
now this check and night c4 or it's
nicely for immediately even better as it
it's almost threatens queen d4 Knight b6
Mary
not clear okay I shall like this check I
mean putting putting the Queen in the
middle of the board where it cannot be
attacked it's very rarely a bad idea
okay um so night see for now right yeah
come on just let's just play this move
it was totally natural one down I don't
think he has a very good reply to it the
question is however how am I going to
continue here and we're going to play
maybe really against the seven porn now
now that's that's possible now it'd be
six this a move not sure maybe sure be
five could could be could be annoying
Roxy five-mile Roxy five attacking d5
this could be could be quite a good move
before this may be Bishop b5 if I
retreat voluntarily that is Queen a 5 mm
okay
is there some point to putting the night
on b6 just to try another strategical
idea night here and maybe trying to
invade on the sea fowl not playing
against these 70 that sets also quite a
valid strategy
this before Bishop b5 a problem you know
probably it's not really a problem but
yeah what's a bit concerned about Roxy 5
before Bishop b5 all that's not really
really a big problem as such but so it's
not really great
now I don't want him to exchange this
Bishop it's not okay i'm doing something
something different here putting this on
the e-file if it goes rook c 5 i'll play
Bishop f3 Bishop b5 night III and okay
you can play Bishop b5 now but this is
not the end of the world it's not really
a big threat possible capture here
yeah it's still fairly solid for black k
well nitey three now
or Bishop f3 yeah my original idea was
Bishop f3 but I just recognized that he
can even just play quinces no that's
before always be formed okay Quincy 7 SB
for winning material or Quincy ate
before wouldn't do him any good Quincy
ate there
996 is not really great okay
okay it would be actually nice if I
could keep both rooks on and maybe get
something in like rookie to look ce1 or
look III Roxy e1 and just get this night
from c4 somewhere else like um yeah why
not to e3 blocking the e-file what I'm
trying to say is I would like to
increase the pressure on his heaven with
the rooks be it would be quite quite
promising yeah it's putting a good I'm
putting up a good defense here always
take into consideration that he's a big
rating on the dog um so look C to D 1
was something like B 3 B 3 a 4
I should I gain space here with be 496 s
also not bad it looks like come on
switching back plenty
yeah I think this was not a good idea oh
wow this is weird really but some way to
directly go about that write a three
this rook b6 yeah Wow
ok I want to I want to keep it simple
here maybe not the best move but it asks
this look very serious question what are
you going to do oh so this looks like it
technically somewhat reliable somewhat
shaky move I take here that's something
wrong with this I'm not quite sure what
but there is something wrong with it
pretty sure
hmm there is no direct tactic against f
66 or something I should take it edit
sets it's okay and now here this is this
is this is unprotected and its own f5
maybe it takes
yeah there are moves like rookie 6 here
locally 6 9 s6 night XD six but this
book takes d5 and this line just a bit
crazy but probably working
and it's not that convincing anyway
maybe I should just drop back rookie 69
f 693 but this it feels like there is
some tactic really f5 takes Queen d3
something like that 27 now then wookie
six ok 92 if I need to play on the night
f6 there is also 93 a kind of keep it
simple approach I'm still wondering
relieved about 96cm 96 rook t5 Queen
takes f6 maybe takes f6 rookie 6 check
wins apiece well isn't this good then
look t5 Queen f6r up to six maybe
and not sure this rook takes 26
sharethis probably not probably a better
end game in a way but not like I'm
winning okay one minute 48 what did I do
with my time I explained quite some nice
subtle points about the Roxy point but
it took Oh Jack this is of course this
is this is very nice I think it was just
a pretty equal end game if he takes on
d6 unless I'm completely completely
screwing up the calculation
yeah still need to win this it's just
one minute so 30-something left which
really should be enough but still needs
to be done we are now Luke c7 rugby 7s
almost unavoidable check
black resigns yeah this was a bit lucky
I believe I mean here look takes d5
queen of six and rock d 6 assists okay i
think for black it's just not much going
on at first i thought that maybe Queenie
five as a move but there is queen bee
skep check this is very embarrassing and
yeah this means you only have this one
and now yeah various ways I mean this is
probably the easiest i can do that but
it probably should be a draw check check
it's very drawing showing check can just
do that maybe i have some activity order
ok'd it will be a draw i am for here it
was a bit a bit of a problem with the
time really Oh ever win here Roxy to you
one ah yeah that's very strong very
strong hmm yeah
this is a very strong move the ideas of
course that this is failing due to a
similar motive to the game and rook
takes this and winning also which means
that black has a big problem here as 96
is a the very substantial idea well yeah
this is probably lost for black computer
wants to play ruka invade but this is
this is impossible to to stand really
long run I can this was the the way this
was also the the big problem with Bishop
g4 I mean I sense that this is just not
right but i didn't i didn't find rupes
e2 e1 I mean this was also due to
simplify the position a bit to make to
be able to make like a moose this was a
um was what I saw as a more complicated
way to play keeping this d5 pawn maybe
queen bee six now I mean the problem is
somewhat off rook let's pick this rook
on b5 is a bit strange you know this is
just not really good I mean he should
just go back to c7 probably the Knight
b6 and well why this is always better
it's got the the space advantage this
slight weakness here only seven and
that's just pressure on blacks position
it cannot do much but this seems like a
like defensible this is just now
completely off this piece and probably
should should be a wind from wide I
didn't see Roxy one though this was
supposed to bit of a problem yeah Gabe p
put up a really a really good defense
here
check oh this is some bit more
comfortable for white but there's
nothing terribly wrong with blacks
position if he goes back in now here and
it's it's just a game white being a bit
better but nothing special all right I
hope you enjoyed the game it was
complicated struggle and some info on
the maracas see behind I guess thanks
for watching